alors voilà aujourd'hui on est on fait
un petit tour à cannes voilages et
j'économise c'est un petit peu pour pour
faire mon tour mon petit tour à cannes
on va essayer de voir un petit peu c'est
ici à des youtube heures ce que j'adore
les youtuber l'année dernière j'ai vu
norman c'était incroyable quand j'ai
pleuré
du coup on essaie de voir chez qui sont
plus vers la voilà j'ai c'est un petit
peu d'avoir un petit photo avec eux pas
un petit souvenir souvenir gravé dans ma
mémoire et dans le téléphone c'est comme
un peu déloger des chauves-souris quoi
on va essayer d avoir en photo est pas
évident je crois qu'à marc chevrier
yamar josé je reviendrai sûrement sur le
terrain photo ensemble ça peut être pas
une petite boîte est juste il retourne
c'est un échec non va je pense qu'on va
faire refaire un taux pouvant sa dot
youtuber youtube je crois que je crois
qu'il ya que marc là bas c'est quand
même ok pas te voir tu adores tombera un
petit saint gobain s'attend ce qui fait
que même s'il te plaît novosti
non je t'ai dit arrête positif
principale information sur moi je suis
peut-être un match où surgit ne met pas
dedans je suis moi tu me suis bien sûr
les régions où l'on voit si de voir ses
assiettes au tube heures un petit peu
sur la croisette quoi on va les chercher
je sens que je sens que ça va plaire ça
alors tu veux c'est non parce que j'ai
réussi à avoir un petit bracelet ça me
suis inscrit pour pouvoir rentrer à la à
la soirée je pense qu'être jeune rachid
et égaux tout seul donc je suis super
super content on va voir si son camp et
c'est passé
bonsoir ça va brasser oui
oh
john john rachiq capable il prend une
photo et spar à moi voici [ __ ] d'avoir
dit avoir porté seul pays où tout seul
coup tout cela va favoriser notre beau
gosse on veut pas de faute au sens le
plus fort ce qu'il fait google domine
moi je sais je suis désolé mais va de sa
petite chute
oui oui tu vois juste à ses fils mais
une photo au poing a laissé un peu chez
un grand soir est je suis détente la
détente la chambre des temps je suis
juste dit oui mais là ça lui
voilà donc on a fait un petit peu le
tour des youtuber bien je pense qu'on
reviendra l'année prochaine
sais pas où
duchaussoy
chien
ta caméra ta caméra
je vous montre une petite photo du
festival les petites les petites fautes
mais youtuber préféré voir élective il
ya que marquis et là il ya un peu tout
le monde j'ai pris une photo à un petit
peu avec tout le monde c'est cool
il ya hugo qui étaient là aussi nous
tout seuls voilà
à